hey I'm go guys but now if you aren't
American there is a specific food that
you already know that you have to
identify with and know that is not Wow
it is the all-american classic hamburger
and in my opinion Americans take pride
in this food as much as they do barbecue
and if you don't like this you might as
well just [ __ ] leave the country
don't quote me on this but I think back
in the day when you immigrated to the
United States if you did it like
hamburgers you were considered a commie
loving but rapist but even for me
growing up even though my mom was an
amazing chef and she cooked bomb-ass
food I always crave a really good
hamburger from Burger King or McDonald's
sponsor me and one of the biggest things
that I loved about hamburgers was how
diverse it was and how it was presented
in a dish now this burger place that I
ate out a couple weeks ago is a joint
called bachi burger I think the original
location is somewhere out in Las Vegas
but not too long ago it opened up in
Pasadena so of course I had to go there
because I'm not driving all the way to
Vegas to taste that [ __ ] it's too far
smells like piss [ __ ] and shame so let's
talk about some of the food that I ate
haha I reviewed the footage apologize
for that face you will see that in your
nightmares the moment when I looked at
the menu my eyes were drawn towards one
item and it was the oxtail chili cheese
fries nothing about what I just said
that's right I said oxtail I said @na I
said the cheese I said that from now
these fries are obviously not like the
normal chili cheese fries that you grew
up with eating and if you don't like
this [ __ ] then you have an Amos for a
tongue oxtail chili and all of its
tender beefy fall-apart goodness it's
topped with a little bit of cilantro
some jalapenos and of course that creamy
aioli then on top of that is a delicious
fried egg and of course where you pop
that egg yo and you let it drizzle down
all over the chili down to the fries
yeah
to my friends you got a boner yet yeah
cuz I do owe information that you
shouldn't share now there's one thing
that I didn't like too much about it
everything was relatively perfectly
except for the temperature of the chili
when I got it served I'm not sure if
that's how they wanted it but the chili
was a little bit on the warm side and I
don't know how to feel about that
because the fries are nice and hot and
crispy and if you get this whatever
temperature Shelly it kind of [ __ ] with
me a little bit but Annette I tell you
mmm the second appetizer that we had was
the grilled artichoke dip I love
artichoke dip especially when it's done
right and that's obviously something
that you've probably eaten at Super Bowl
parties but this is not one of those
things it was salty it was creamy it was
cheesy and of course when you top that
off with a little bit of the fried
lobster it's added that porky goodness
that it needed they can dip that with
the chip and put it in your mouth and
then you go to heaven and then after
that you have second that wasn't my
favorite dish
no and the main reason why was because
it's kind of labeled as a crap artichoke
dip but because of all the other
ingredients
I think the crab got lost in it and I
didn't get that flavor profile and I
wanted now let's talk about the burger
experience one of the top things that I
love about bocce is their presentation
because it's always on point
look at that you tell me right now that
you couldn't throw that on ugly person's
face and it'll change a whole
perspective on that club everyone's
honor L and they call this fat flavor
and these burgers is something that it
does not lack and even though it looks
extremely decadent it's not as heavy as
you think now we all know what makes a
burger shine the most and it has to be
all about the past
the combination of beef that they're
gonna use in the majority of their
burgers it's gonna be a combo of a well
a Chuck short rib and brisket and for
the dishes with pork in it they're only
going to use Duroc pork or could've buta
pork now if you guys don't know what
Duroc and kurobuta pork is uh you got
google [ __ ] use it the burger that I
ate and enjoyed thoroughly was the
miyagi-san
and oh this patty was made for Wagyu
beef it had a delicious fried egg top
with a little bit of food a cocky
sweetness from these caramelized onions
and a textural crunch from this Brad
onion thingy just ahh the food
experiencer was pretty bomb I'm probably
gonna go ahead and try that [ __ ] again
and if you guys want to sample a lot of
things I suggest you go with a lot of
friends you guys get different burgers
and then you could try a lot more things
out and of course if you're going to
this restaurant and you are on a diet
and you are counting calories it's
pretty easy you just got to go online
get on Yelp go to the search bar and
look for another [ __ ] place to eat
how [ __ ] long did it take me to
memorize that line [ __ ] when I came into
this country I got an American starter
kit it was filled with guns bullets
hamburgers and divorce papers